Mr Beast recently turned down a one  billion dollar offer for his YouTube  channel he said maybe if it was a 10 or  20 billion I would even consider it do  you think that uh he made a bad call  let's do some basic math his most viewed  video is 293 million views it's a 25  minute video that's the 456 000 squid  game Super Bowl commercial you do 30  seconds what are you paying 5.2 million  dollars give or take right  and Super Bowl gets roughly a hundred  million views he's got total 17 billion  views I'll just do the number on 17  billion views we can do together right  now on just one channel okay let's do  this together 17 billion views divided  by 100 million because that's what Super  Bowl claims so that's 170 times  5 million bucks his one channel alone  has generated a minimum of 850 million  dollars and I'm calculating only one  commercial and then add it to all the  other channels that he has I think he's  right 10 to 20 billion dollars the right  number